okay let's go to the phones at six one
seven eight three zero forty seven fifty
many many people waiting anxiously to
say their piece we'll start today with
our caller from the three two three area
code who's calling today from three to
three
hello yes that's you now I have two
questions for you
okay what do you think they can do about
the Georgia delays and in uh the
election so corrupt there that I just
III would I would hope that you know
black lives matter would also like
gather around the Georgia City Hall and
protest that because they're just
disenfranchising people yep we talked
about this earlier in the week and if
you want a preview of the voter
disenfranchisement and election fraud
tactics that we are going to see in
November just look at what happened in
Georgia earlier this week and you know
certainly it has not been a focus of the
protests over the last ten days that
that's that's okay the protests were
about something else but we need every
nonprofit that works on voter
disenfranchisement activated we need to
overwhelm the vote by so much that even
by cheating they can't win but if if
anybody doubted and at this point I
don't know why you would if anybody
doubted what we are going to see in
November we saw it in Georgia this week
and there's no one solution it's we've
got to push for vote by mail we've got
to push for not closing polling places
prevent the voter roll purges anybody
who can vote early should anybody who
can vote by mail should but we've got to
overwhelm the vote because they're going
to try to take it with these tactics we
they do it every year and Trump is extra
desperate right now yeah well that's
that's not by chance the idea is make it
harder to vote in places where at the at
the in the average people are more
likely to vote for Democrats and you had
people who vote in overwhelmingly white
precincts in Georgia saying I don't know
what people are talking about
showed up I voted in five minutes there
was nobody there are plenty of voting
booths and everything's fine that's the
strategy yeah yeah I heard that I heard
there was a woman at the polls who said
that she drove she acted waiting for
three hours she drove to a white place
and thought people just walking in there
wasn't even a line yep it's uh it's
predictable and it's horrible
yeah and then my finally final comment
is with the Joe Rogan interview I love
Joe Rubens but you like to be using you
like a I don't know like you you're his
psychologist or so because he just
talked so much more than normal you're
just like I was like David say something
I didn't know - I didn't notice that to
be perfectly frank yeah he was going on
and on and I was like Joe let's talk a
lot more but he was it was like he was
waiting for you like you know I need to
unload the David coming so I could just
gave it's very polite so I'm just gonna
talk and talk I don't know if that was
real you know when when when it's done
via Skype like I wasn't in the room with
Joe it sometimes may be tougher to read
when it would be a natural time for the
other person to talk so maybe that was a
factor but in the moment I didn't notice
it didn't seem that way right but maybe
maybe maybe cuz he doesn't see you there
he feels it sort of maybe a little bit
of an anxiety in order to try to fill
the moment maybe something keeps talking
because he doesn't see your physical
cues right you're ready to jump in keep
going and going well anyway thank you so
much I'm a huge fan I'm a member you
know and I recommended my cousin to be
your member and not anybody who I've
talked to about in terms of like you
know getting a good news source I told
them you know David Patten is one of the
best thank you for he'll secular talk
with kolinsky yeah so you guys are a
number one fantastic alright appreciate
it thank you so much take care great to
hear from you